[Musik]
[Applaus]
angst sich das entscheiden das ist
falsch
[Musik]
in vier wochen kann man die abholen
diesen kitzel jung die bahn von der
mutter getrennt von den geschwistern
getrennt die kommen eine fremde umgebung
diese autobahn ist stress und damit viel
zu viel für diese jungen wölfen die sind
vom immunsystem unreifen
nach einer kontrolle wenn man sie bitte
geld und bilder von mit träumen zu
dürfen
[Musik]
deutsch massiv manipuliert wurde mit dem
geburtsdatum das geordnet
humor kommen selbst nicht so kein
deutsch
es ist welten ach ja das ist
vergleichbar zu drogenhandel daran und
laufen sie sollen damit verdient
ich habe eben darauf dass sie die ziele
zu wenig getränkt und gefüttert habe das
ist nicht normal
verdammt noch mal
[Musik]
die hat erst seit ich kannte mich
braucht
[Musik]
die kamen heute in der not war zu uns
sind beide aus kroatien importiert
worden
die beiden welpen sind geschwister tiere
die hündin ist sehr schlecht
jetzt immer gerade in die
intensivstation rein
und sie sehen wir haben immer mehr
absperrungen immer mehr frühchen teheran
solchen tiere
meist haben sie parvovirose eine
gefährliche viren krankheit unbehandelt
sterben die welten
die hunde strecken sich oft auf dem
transport in die schweizer an
[Musik]
bisschen kranken welpen gab es schon
immer aber das ausmaß des momentan
annimmt ist absolut
dass er ist wirklich sehr grenzwertig so
schlimm wie momentan habe ich noch nie
erlebt man jetzt waren das fünf welpen
seit montag das heißt das eigentlich
einer pro tag jetzt die leute legen sie
jetzt extrem viel hunde zu wir denken
dass ich alles krise bedingt was das
heißt dass ich einfach dass die infusion
nicht läuft
das kann nicht sein dass ein füße
abbogen es je jünger die menschen desto
weniger immunschutz desto eher werden
sie krank wir halten uns riskiert das
ist jetzt gerade acht wochen und sechs
tage glaube ich genau also wirklich
zumindest sieht das muss überhaupt
richtig
darunter ich es kam also brauchen
wir die sagt es ist eine beziehung wie
die sich dann schnell
also vom gesetz her denn korrekt
importiert für mich sind wir ganz klar
zu jung weil die sind eben sehr ein
verlegtes jungtiere und bei adam und ich
weiß nicht ob sie das hören jetzt
hochstätter auch noch gilt schnecken
sich wahrscheinlich
verschluckt beim brecher die schweizer
acht wochen regel ist viel weniger
streng als jene in fast allen
westeuropäischen ländern dort müssen
welpen mindestens 15 wochen alt sein bis
sie importiert werden dürfen
es tut mir leid also wir haben ja
verraten die flut ergebnisse ab und die
blut ergebnisse senat gut
das heißt wir haben bei rocky und bei
sky
diesmal die paar wochen rose diese hunde
solche kann einfach nicht versprechen
dass es beide überleben wird die
behandlung heißt es dass sie damit
rechnen müssen dass sie beide zusammen
kommen sicher deutlich über 7000 franken
das ist von unten billige sache
beruhigen das sonst sonst tafel moni
aber wenn sie sich verdient wenn sie
sich das nicht leisten können die
behandlung dann müssen sie das
frühzeitig sagen
na gut mir haben das wirklich nicht
gewusst wie das alles so läuft und dann
wird mir haben einfach freude gehabt das
kaufen und so das ist unsere priorität
aber jetzt habe mobilen das ist eine
große galaxie
und rocky kosteten 1200 euro kann der
besitzer ihre behandlung nicht bezahlen
müssen sie eingeschläfert werden er will
die summe in raten abzahlen
[Musik]
hallo
nehmen wir das mädchen sophie ihre
eltern haben einen zwergspitz bestellt
[Musik]
sophies hund hat keinen chip ist also
illegal und schlimmer noch er stammt
vermutlich aus moldawien ein land mit
tollwut gefahr
welche krankheit zahlen hat in die
schweiz gebracht werden dass das
verstanden
jetzt
kann ein cockpit erhalten hat
bei der iss herzlich bei tollwut gefahr
werden viele hunde eingeschläfert
aber der kantonstierarzt hat eine
ausnahme gemacht und eine quarantäne für
sophies welpe angeordnet
[Musik]
es wird sich herausstellen dass das tier
keine tollwut hat die zahl der wegen
tollwutgefahr eingeschläfert 100 aber
hat sich in den letzten zehn jahren mehr
als verdoppelt
das ist
das ist für mich ein alptraum
[Musik]
ich warte auf den amtstierarzt von st
gallen
matthias thieme wird gerufen wenn etwas
mit einem importierten hund nicht stimmt
zum beispiel wenn der zoll einen hunde
transport aus osteuropa kontrolliert und
sieht dass die tiere keine pässe haben
und somit illegal ins land kommen
[Musik]
so heißt bis zwei
komplexe illegale import verlieh dem
buch gearbeitet pro woche zwei bis 2 5
hektar bevergern zalando mentalität also
mit stellt online matthias liefere fotos
türe und wenn es eine basis wieder
zurück
wie findet sie auch persönlich getroffen
ich finde ganz schlimm
letztes jahr wurden fast
31000 importierte hunde registriert eine
rekordzahl dazu kommen die illegalen
importe laut so letztes jahr mindestens
7000 600 hunde
ja genau
im moment haben wir vor allem die
organisation große probleme damit konnte
sich die firma eat dog slowakei mit den
transportunternehmen taktik
und das läuft alle 14 tage ab doch und
immer das gleiche fahrzeug von carl benz
das problem ist dass dir mit
manipulierten swisscom mitteilt gab es
und daran ist bobby spiel
das ist so eine slowakische heimtierpass
ausstellungsdatum und dann sehen sie das
eigentlich da wo max irrt wenn man den
basar lage ton ihren das eine bild
runter man eine spezielle diät gemacht
worden ist den zeichner oder 2 20 22 21
die firma eat dog mache
urkundenfälschung gleich wie ein mensch
hat ein hund einen pass seine identität
wörtlich gott darum horste
will das ist das risiko der hundehandel
und mehr vermutet dass der so einen pass
vorstellbar franken und das kann man
unter umständen günstiger machen dass
man einfach ein pass von hund und werner
platziert werde wieder überschrieben
wird tragischer sind da nicht die bilder
wieder im kicker
also wird dabei die hitzige manipuliert
sodass heißt es sich in geschäften
oder
also
optimistisch ich hoffe wir schon das
gift wohnen nicht ich weiß es ehrlich
gesagt da nicht ganz genau und um
auckland dass da wirklich massiv
manipuliert haben wir entschieden
sortiert er einmal vorübergehend
beschlagnahmen das sind sie der wenigen
zurückgeholt und h7 tierheim im kanton
st gallen denn deponiert
[Musik]
nach kaum
widerhall
im grunde
[Musik]
ein schieber innovent von elite bestellt
von anthony motor dessen eignung wurde
vom st galler tierheim abgeklärt bevor
ihr den hund bekam aber wir sehen sie
dann ruft
sie das wort zieht der 56 90
das ja jetzt
nicht der zog sie weil ich verspüre dass
man bekommt
man wenn man tv schnell
es so funke die liebe zum ersten blick
jetzt einmal und das ist dann charlie
wird sagt sie januar wirksam in szene
und fragt ob denn
[Musik]
das ist die andere frage das ist die
angelegt war
mit solchen videos verkauft aldi talk
welt
ja am anfang
und es ist nach so xie form transport
datumsproblem
[Musik]
wer im internet welten kaufen sucht
gelangt auf die seite welpen kaufen
punkt ch der firma alt doch in der
slowakei
und besitzt auch die domain welten
kaufen.de weil sie auch hunde nach
österreich verkauft
der wunsch so quasi wie noch im sommer
stehen
für mir jetzt mal von videos oder
telefonisch kontakt aufgenommen seine
person und
das ist sagen wir also an ihr nachname
krog wird sie mit der sonne sichere
gaildorf
die arbeit zum beispiel das im rückraum
der zahlen des fundbüros und 200 casey
chan kanada
drei tage später wieder versandet doppel
und gesendet also fünf transportiert
versendet so wie sehr ich mach das so
sind erste wahl
[Musik]
das will ich jetzt danke
kriminelle organisation
unterstützt mit
[Musik]
hertie besitzer von aldi talk in der
slowakei heißt seine hunde handelsfirma
taktik gegründet 2007
in seinem jacuzzi gefilmt vom
slowakischen fernsehen
955 welpen exportierte er letztes jahr
laut slowakischer veltliner behörde die
meisten hunde presse hat ein einziger
tierarzt ausgestellt
drk im pandemie jahr 2020 verdoppelte
die hunde handelsfirma taktik ihren
umsatz auf über eine halbe million euro
bei 955 exportierten hunden und einem
durchschnittlichen verkaufspreis von
1200 euro pro hund ohne mehrwertsteuer
hat taktik aber rund eine million umsatz
gemacht also rund doppelt so viel wie
die firma meldet
eine stunde von der slowakischen
hauptstadt entfernt liegt ballon 1 700
seelen dorf im süden des landes
wir filmen versteckt hier am
geschäftssitz von anydoc und taktik
haben wir uns als kaufinteressenten
angemeldet
als erstes fällt mir auf der weise
siegträume berlingo ich erkenne das
nummernschild damit wurden welten
transportiert die in st gallen
beschlagnahmt wurden
die frau die uns begrüßt heißt angeblich
julia es ist dieselbe person die ich auf
den videos der hunde käufe gesehen habe
im vergleich zu den häusern in der
umgebung ist dieses anwesen luxuriös in
der ferne sehen wir zwinger mit rund
einem dutzend hunden in seide sagen 'es
liegt süchte maximal zehn prozent der
welpen die die firma verkaufen der rest
werde zugekauft
julia führt uns zu einem käfig mit zwei
malteser welpen
sie seien zwölf wochen alt zu jung für
den export in viele eu-länder editor
knitz die schwachen gesetze der schweiz
und österreich aus und verkaufte hunde
fast nur dorthin allerdings verschärft
österreich auf ende jahr sein gesetzt
ich frage mich sind keine zwerg spitze
vor ort oder könnten sie im hinteren
teil dieses hauses seien
in solchen boxen so wurden welten vor
vier jahren gehalten vor einem groß
transport nach belgien das belgische
fernsehen hat damals versteckt im haus
gedreht
könnte etwas passieren auf den
vorstellungen sehen
ich weiß nicht so bewegen uns die weg
links von mir von der bombe ist
entschärft werden richtig schönes fest
steht sie hätte das match in seoul mit
wir sind hier zu dem raum
infinite
druck auf die high stake magnetisch
also die checker hat
parvovirose die wurde
bestellt wurde geliefert
die bringen jetzt wissen mit liebig also
muss die heimat dann ist
kronawitter
haben sie nach ihm das ist china reise
von o bis
der transport mit chika fand einen monat
nach der beschlagnahmung in st gallen
statt schicker wurde von ihren käufern
über die schweizer grenze gebracht bei
gefälschten papieren hätten sie gehaftet
[Musik]
chica war auf einem transport mit vier
anderen hunden
auch dieser malteser war dabei
auch da
blutiger durchfall auch lars hat
parvovirose
hier zeigt sich das problem sehr junge
welpen aus mutmaßlich schlechten zuchten
mit wenig immunschutz werden zusammen
transportiert und stecken sich
vermutlich gegenseitig an
der käufer von lars aber wie nicht für
seine behandlung zahlen
[Musik]
ich habe mich nur ums geld nicht um
gesund es ist direkt nach der abgabe
nummer gefragt worden
wären sie sich in den keller wo man den
hund adoptieren also es hat sich herum
gesprochen worden
genau richtig
das ist extrem verstehen das macht
extrem wichtig also mit - aber wie das
saubere wasser mit einer lüge
kommuniziert dass man nicht unfair wird
mit der wirklichkeit es besser was macht
ein so traurig und es macht einen so
heiß ich also ich wirklich es macht
einfach mehr
los hat glück im unglück kollegen der
tierärztinnen übernehmen ihn und seine
kosten
steht dass man nie schläft hat dass er
klargestellt dass wir das wunschziel ist
einfach unverantwortlich und es ist
egoistisch
rund jeder fünfte hunde im zürcher
tierspital stamme von elli talk sagen
die ärzte
woher aber stammen chica und die anderen
hunde die eliten verkauft
[Musik]
einfach nicht von euch
die frau widerspricht sich lässt dann
die angebliche mutter bringen verglichen
mit den welpen ist sie sehr klein
suchen wir also noch den züchtern die
welpen nate dogg verkauft haben ich habe
einige adressen zugespielt bekommen mit
dabei journalist solo mit cash
ja ich habe mich ein bisschen gecheckt
und da sind keine normale züchter und
sie vermehren die kinder nur bei aus
einem etwas einen nebenjob
landwirtschaft dar oder sind auch
chauffeurs es ist wahrscheinlich ein
schwarzes namen geschäft
vom sitz von anydoc aus fahren wir durch
die südslowakei
solo mitspricht slowakisch und ungarisch
[Musik]
hier lebt ein ehepaar das schon welt
genannt elli doch verkauft hat die frau
sagt sie hätten einen neuen wurf von
malteser welpen wir fragen ob wir die
hundemutter sehen können
warum ist das wichtig sie möchten einen
hund kaufen und es ist wichtig für sie
die mutter hunde zu sehen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht recht
zögerlich führt zu uns ins haus
sie habe drei muttertiere zweimal im
jahr werden sie gedeckt mehr als
biologisch gar nicht möglich
die frau missbraucht die muttertiere als
gebärmaschinen die kontrollierte
schweizer zucht erlaubt nur einen wurf
pro jahr
bei susi sieht man die zitzen eindeutig
hier also ist die zucht zwischen
hinterhof und haus es stinkt nach urin
und kot
die sechs welten stammen von den drei
müttern schlechte würfe sagt die frau
und das habe seinen grund
pelletier wirkte babys der anderen
mütter und das ist nicht so einfach
gitti und bundes haben zur gleichen zeit
welpen bekommen und erinnert einer nacht
hat kitty alle welpen von bondy getötet
wir nennen sie jetzt kritik
leider könne sie uns keinen welten
verkaufen sie habe alle einen
großhändler in der nähe versprochen den
namen sagt sie nicht er bezahle 250 euro
pro hund doch verkauft einen malteser
für 1000 euro und mit lieferung in die
schweiz für 1400
einmal hatte ich die welpen einem
händler versprochen aber dann hat ein
anderer mehr geld offeriert ich habe die
tiere dem meistbietenden verkauft und
ärger mit dem anderen gekriegt
es geht um viel geld
die welpen bringen rund 5000 euro pro
jahr ein in dieser gegend entspricht das
im schnitt 5 monatslöhnen
[Musik]
das stimmt nicht ich habe transport
papiere die zeigen dass elli doch viele
hunde in ungarn aufkauft zum teil sind
sie in ungarn aber nicht registriert und
kommen illegal in die slowakei
seit letztem sommer aber gibt es dort
nur noch die eigene firma aus absender
an und verschleiert so wer die welpen
gezüchtet hat
wir fahren weiter durch die slowakei
hier wahrscheinlich
auch der nächste züchter hat schon welt
doch verkauft
guten tag
wir möchten einen hund kaufen
dieser mann bietet uns zwei golden
retriever an 300 euro pro welt auch für
einen golden retriever verlangt lockt
1000 euro ohne transport
insider sagte milito kaufe wänden schon
ab 100 euro auf
ja ich kann das organisieren mein freund
ist tierart er hat pässe und mikrochips
ich frage nach ganz jungen welten der
mann bringt ein drei wochen altes tier
er hat ein problem er
hat einlochen gruppe
1 geburtsgebrechen
entwickelt sich nicht gut
die neuen welten boxen in dieser kleinen
stall box auf
der man sagt er sei arbeitslos erlebe
von der zucht von hunden und hühnern in
der slowakei gibt es keine obergrenze
fürs formieren von bunten es wird
darüber diskutiert prozent maximal drei
hündinnen zu erlauben
wir fahren weiter nach ungarn
stundenlang liebes land richtung
rumänien
im dorf kabal treffen wir auf ein
auffallend schönes haus die frau sagt
sie züchtet die hunde eine spezielle
ungarische rasse ihre hunde hätten schon
preise bekommen
die welpen seien zwei wochen alt
in vier wochen können sie sie abholen
kein problem die welpen halten das schon
aus solche transporte wurden schon oft
gemacht die preis züchterin würde uns
die welpen mit sechs wochen also klar zu
jung verkaufen auch laut ungarischen
gesetz sorgen wenn dann erst mit acht
wochen von ihren müttern getrennt werden
um das prämierte muttertier hat
vermutlich eine zwangsstörung sagen
spezialisten
weiter in den süden ungarns
schuld ist einen haupt stunden von der
serbischen grenze entfernt und in
serbien gibt es noch tollwut
auch von hier wurden schon hunderte male
tag verkauft eine roma familie zeigt uns
französische bulldoggen
erhard orten probleme seine nase ist zu
eng dazu starke hautfalten und
verkrustete uhren beides anfällig für
entzündungen
für ihn wollen sie
2003 lila und eine mary zucht das heißt
gesprenkelt beides heikle genetische
mutationen in der schweizer stammbaum
zucht nicht zugelassen
wir verlangen den pass des lila welpen
geboren im dezember 2020
nein das ist das im staat um
wir haben
kommen und auch andere und geschaffen
sowie des werkstücks oder malteser
connection kein problem
und weiter geht's zur nächsten familien
[Musik]
auch sie wollen uns welten schon mit
sechs wochen verkaufen
je jünger die welt desto weniger geld
müssen sie für futter ausgeben und auch
sie haben mehr sprenkel unter einem
blauen farbton es besteht die gefahr
dass die tiere erblinden oder taub
werden
wenn sie angucken der hund hat keine
nasen und
wahrscheinlich sind die nasenlöcher
hingehen klein deshalb können die hunde
bei hitze zum beispiel im sommer
spazieren geführt haben wir kriegen
einfach keine luft die hunde seien
ergänzt sich aus diese großen augen und
ist es wenn es zurückbringen der neiße
das
machen macht eben dieses baby face und
es mögen das spricht menschen an es ist
ganz klare qual zu die hunde haben auch
keine lange längst erwartung für mich
ist es eigentlich eine weltmacht ihr
auch mal ganz deutlich zu sagen es wird
einfach von mir von mir vermehrbar mit
kammern extrem gut geld machen
jetzt haben wir hier
[Musik]
es ist einfach so ein moment wo man dann
emotional
also bisher selber denkt auch
viel einsatz und schicker hat viel
einsatz auch in der kleinen maus sie hat
gekämpft oder man sieht dann verlor man
fällt irgendwie ja auch bis jetzt
zusammen in einer kämpft die ganze zeit
das spät abends immer versucht so zu
geben damit sie überleben und dann
gehts so wie man sich gewünscht hat
oder wenn man gehofft hat dann ist man
wieso bisher fällt bis er endlich
zusammen glaube ich
die situation
ja sich besonders schlimm wenn man runde
verliert muss einfach absolut unnötig
gewesen wäre
jetzt bitte die bei welpen entpuppen
diese dieses leiden von diesen hund
nicht mein dicker war schwer krank das
ist ja nett auch wenn wir behandeln was
schmerzen gegeben wenn wir inklusion
geben das ist für den hund kein
spaziergang gewesen sondern sie hat eine
leidenszeit kommt und diese leidenszeit
posiert mit überleben belohnt sondern
mit tod beendet und das ist nichts das
ist nichts schönes
ich hatte zuerst die besitzerin am
telefon zwei furchtbar fax telefon anja
man weiter gegeben
und
er war geschockt
habe zuerst nicht auf die anrufe der
familie reagiert später dann habe die
firma angeboten einen neuen home zu
schicken
würden sie dann sagt verantwortet jetzt
für der tod ist schlussendlich bittere
firma eat dog bo der hund weder züchter
gekauft und lufttransporte hat ich sehe
es komme jetzt in mv die firma elektro
haftbar machen findet vor dem team was
nützt das wenn sie die firma haftbar
machen
bleibt tot
die wirklich strange größer und der
verhandlungen das ist eine lehre es tut
mir leid wenn der bereich für mich ist
der entscheidende punkt wenn man die
hunde nicht bestellt und kauft dann
haben sie keinen markt so lange der
endverbraucher den hund bestellt ist der
markt da und so lange rechnet sich das
für irgend jemand der keine skrupel hat
[Musik]
bisher spielt der freie markt der staat
setzt auf die eigenverantwortung der
konsumentinnen und konsumenten
ob das aber reicht denn china ist kein
einzelfall
ich weiß von drei weiteren elite welpen
die dieses jahr kurz nach dem transport
verstorben
ein labrador im februar nahe graz ein
malteser auf einem alley transport im
märz der in wien kontrolliert wurde
und lucie verstorben mitten in der nacht
im juli in niederhasli ich bezahlt drei
bin ich verärgert weil ich irgendwas
völker irgendein bestimmten nummer dann
hat sie mich so richtig mit ihrer
flugzeuge hat römer geschnuppert und
dann hat es heute einfach auf die links
sigrid und hat sie sich nicht mehr
bewegt
sich ihnen starben qualvoll gestorben
die autopsie ergab
lucy verstorben parvovirose
zweieinhalb tage nach dem transport mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit hatte sie sich
schon vor der reise infiziert
hat auch wissen die hand nur us-werke
und so quasi märkte und verkauft die
eingriffe größtes problem
ist eine mögliche marsch für begangene
wird der hund läuft und was das für sich
das einfach alles wachsen
zusammen mit einer ungarischen
übersetzerin kontaktiere ich den chef
von eliten herze bestreitet die
todesfälle bei hammond
glaubt sie nicht her dass eine illegale
unterhändler aus der slowakei oder
ungarn fälle verursacht hat und dass er
uns lassen die schulstiftung uns zu
schaden
nein diese hunde wurden bei anydoc
bestellt
es ist nicht wahr wir haben wir haben
mit den besitzern gesprochen haben die
tiere gesehen die schweizer mögen und
[Gelächter]
sie ich sage die wahrheit die hunde kaum
verlassen ihre welt bei minus fünf grad
in einer kalten zu spielen und wenn die
tiere dann sterben was kann ich dafür
aber
immer heißt es das parco virus ist das
problem das cargo wer ist das
in der slowakei sind großhändler wie
herr t auf tierärzte angewiesen ein
einziger tierarzt hat in den letzten
jahren tausende pässe für elektrik
welpen unterschrieben
doktor komm wir suchen sie eine praxis
auf
guten tag wir suchen drk
er ist nicht zu hause
ksv gibt uns eine telefonnummer sie
sollen ihn anrufen
ich rufe an weil das schweizer fernsehen
dokumente hat die beweisen dass hunde
pässe gefälscht sind hesse die sie
unterschrieben haben
unmöglich sagt drk heim tier pässe seien
fälschungssicher unsere papier aber
zeigen das gegenteil
ex geschäftspartner von elli talks
sorgen tierärzte hätten blanco pässe und
electric verkauft drk bestreitet das
was weiß und macht die staatliche
veterinär behörde gegen aids tag in
bratislava erfahren wir der name der
firma ist bekannt im juli sei sie
letztmals kontrolliert worden sagt
veterinär chef josef bearish
es gab mehrere probleme die transport
papiere waren nicht in ordnung die
zuchtbedingungen war nicht gut und die
impfungen nicht korrekt zwar wurde
geimpft aber nach der tollwutimpfung
muss man drei wochen warten bis die
impfung wirkt
diese fest wurde nicht abgewartet die
hunde würden zu früh exportiert außerdem
konnten wir nicht klären von welchen
züchtern die hunde stammen
es drohen bußen
2011 habe man die firma letzmals gebüßt
mit 350 euro tierarzt karsai nie gebüsst
worden fehlbare tiere jetzt der aber
kämen in eine risikogruppe und würden
regelmäßig kontrolliert wie viele haben
das kann ich ihnen nicht genau sagen
aber ich denke es ist eine gruppe von
circa 50 personen
das ist ein großes problem
nein das ist wirksame kontrolle der
fall liegt spielt sich in thun ist
austria ab einem bezirk in der
südslowakei die regionale
veterinärbehörde müsste jeden hund der
ins ausland fährt vor dem transport auf
seine gesundheit überprüfen warum fällt
bei fast 1000 exportierten hunden
letztes jahr nichts auf insider vermuten
korruption wir rufen den amtstierarzt an
der die meisten editor kunde vor dem
transport für gesund erklärt hat
könnten sie uns ein interview geben zum
hundehandel heute oder morgen
ich bin nicht zuständig auf keinen fall
könnten sie uns etwas sagen zur pass
fälschung der firma taktik
ja das würde ich schon
würden sie korruption in den oscars
trader anschließen
es gibt hinweise auf gewisse leute
aber es ist nichts konkretes
wenn es konkret ist werde ich dieses
problem lösen wenn es konkret status
aber die frage ist glauben sie hätten
bisher genug unternommen
in bezug auf kontrolle wir müssen die
kontrollen verstärken
das heißt also bisher wurde zu wenig
gemacht wenn sie die kontrolle
verstärken wollen
wir bieten risikoanalysen
habe ja oder nein
denken sie dass sie mehr tun müssten
mehr immer mehr
wir zeigen ihnen die fälschungen die
schweizer kantons tierärzte haben von
mitte 2019 bis anfang dieses jahres
350 unregelmäßigkeiten bei 5 111 fällen
gefunden
das ist neu für mich
sind sie besorgt
wenn sich die 350 fälle bestätigen dann
ist das ein grund die firma zu schließen
individual aber ich brauche die
einzelnen fälle von ihrem land
das ist sehr wichtig
was außer läuft beim bundesamt für
veterinärwesen
hier wurden die manipulierten el dok
fälle aus der ganzen schweiz gesammelt
das macht die firma
hat die schweiz die 350 fälle der
slowakei gemeldet nein sagt die
tierschutz verantwortliche mit dem
tierschutzgesetz gesetzlichen grundlage
zum vater
wirkt wenn er unzufrieden sind mit der
firma wo immer bitterer das molekül
jähriger oder falsche gemacht könnt ihr
nicht einfach der behörde in einem
landauer und ihr vorteile so dass die
ihr kind freuen und
eigentlich mit
das ist skandalös
wenn möglich - die aber das flüchtige
gesetzesänderung oder zum zum
datenschutz sache sie immer sehr
viel egal ob die
authentische cd projekt im moment der
datenschutz der tierschutz
ich informiere lief sieg über ein
gespräch mit dem chef der slowakischen
veterinärbehörde
er hat gesagt ich brauche dringend die
fans der schweiz mit über 50 fahren doch
wenn wir die firma zu machen
daher muss die gesamte gesucht die es
machen kann man probieren also probieren
kann es immer noch nicht vor
sind sie jetzt im inneren position nicht
an generaldirektor
das ist es
sowieso
also aber oder ventile mediziner über
eine kontaktaufnahme allen show aber
natürlich mit wenn wir irgendwo hier
problems tätig ist das nicht glücklich
als ich sie eine woche später nochmals
anrufe heißt es man wolle zuerst die
strafuntersuchung in der schweiz
abwarten
[Musik]
also hat man machen kann ohne nehmen sie
bitte geld und telefon mit können sie
mit
verstand sie nicht nicht
die welt und telefon kontrolle mit mir
nicht
es ist früh morgens an einem freitag in
der august
ein transport von elli talk wird
kontrolliert
[Musik]
o
wie viele hundert swb
88 und von roh sind die hunde sondern
waren auch
der slowakei alfons lauer
diesmal wurden die pässe der welpen
nicht manipuliert geburtsdaten und
impfungen sind nur einmal eingetragen
stimmen seiner papiere
geschickt
was sie herausgefunden hat zu der firma
recherchierte ist das zum teil zyperns
ungarn aber sie sind gar nicht
registriert in ungarn und sich mit einer
steten slowaken baus
überdies kann jetzt gerne zeigt also wir
können immer die slowakische basterds
und die anomalie mit der ganzen hand und
das ist eigentlich das gaben ihre der
verzollung also ja
[Musik]
auch matthias diener ist hier der
amtstierarzt der anfang jahr ad hoc
welpen wegen fälschungen beschlagnahmt
hat
[Musik]
die wenigen ausfluss sein
und der farbe rot
sz dieses klären
sein
wird als das sind
verbrecher
ist noch kathrin moneta branche betrifft
die acht wochen also das
neue produkt fall hat
grundsätzliche frage audio experte kann
mir zeit auch woche nicht vorsätzlich
okay aber die die es in der attraktion
ist machen wir uns da wir nicht mit
deutschem pass sortieren krankheit das
ganze gut wie heute habe ich eigentlich
nur dürfen beantworte ich setzen auf
aussetzung im moment aber das ist eh
nichts wenn die persönliche meinung ist
dass es sich eine kurswende hinter jung
transportiert werden der bund prüft
jetzt ob das mindestalter bei import
welten erhöht werden soll
polizei bilder eines el dok transports
der letzten herbst im tirol gestoppt
wurde sechs von neun welpen zu jung und
einige auch krank auf der fahrt zu wenig
gefüttert und getränkt
meine recherchen ergeben diese
chauffeure mussten bussen bezahlen und
haben damit den tatbestand der
tierquälerei
anerkannt
sie haben sechs hundewelpen über längere
zeit einen qualvollen zustand ausgesetzt
weil sie zu wenig gefüttert und getränkt
ist als quälerei ist das quälerei wenn
ein hund durchfall hat und der tierarzt
sagt er ist transportfähig was sollen
wir dann machen
[Applaus]
mit einem deutschen würden sie nicht so
sprechend ein deutscher würde sich ihre
vorwürfe nicht bieten lassen
ich habe genug es geht mir auf die
nerven die busse haben wir gekriegt weil
sie die tiere zu wenig getränkt und zu
wenig gefürchtet haben
das ist nicht nur machen verdammt noch
mal
wieso nicht einfach der online-handel
frau bezüglich meines die jährigen etwas
zauber und heute statt
absolut minimaler wie so eine blüte
passt so für mich alles aber wer will
den konsumentinnen und konsumenten schon
vorschreiben was sie kaufen dürfen und
was nicht
die
hamburger waren zwar endlich stufe
schritt sondern wir jetzt international
[Musik]